so let's dig a little bit more into
matrices and their inverses and in
particular i'm going to explore
the situations in which there might not
be an inverse for a matrix
so just as a review we think about if we
have some matrix a
is there some other matrix which we
could call a inverse that when we take
the composition of them
so if we view them each as
transformations we would end up with the
identity transformation or if we take
the product of the two
you get the identity matrix and we would
also
think about it well if a inverse undoes
a then a
should undo a inverse to also get
the identity matrix and so another way
to think about it
if i take some type of
region in the coordinate plane so this
is my x-axis this is my y-axis
and so let's say my original region
looks something
like this right over here and i apply
the transformation
a and i get something that looks like
this
just making up some things so if i apply
the transformation
a it takes me from that region to that
region
then we also have a sense that okay a
inverse
if you if you transformed this purple
thing should take you back
to where you began because if you start
with this little blue
thing and if you have the composition
well then that should just be
transforming it with the identity
transformation so you should just get
back
to this little blue thing here now this
might start triggering some thoughts
about determinants
because you might remember that the
determinant of a matrix
tells us how much a region's area will
be scaled by
in particular let's say that
matrix a takes a region that has an
area of i don't know let's call this
area
b and let's take let's say it takes that
area
to 5 times b so the area here
is 5b well we know that that
scaling of 5 you can determine from the
determinant of matrix a
that would tell us that the absolute
value of the determinant
of matrix a is going to be equal to 5.
but what does that tell us about the
absolute value of the determinant
of a inverse then well
if a is scaling up by five it scales
areas up by five
then a inverse must be scaling areas
down by five so the absolute value of
the determinant of a inverse should be 1
over 5. and so now we have a general
property i just happen to use the number
5 here but generally speaking
the absolute value of the determinant
of matrix a if it has an inverse should
be equal to
1 over the absolute value of the
determinant
of a inverse and we could of course
write that the other way around
the absolute value of the determinant of
a inverse
should be equal to 1 over or the
reciprocal of
the absolute value of the determinant of
a this comes straight out of this
property that the absolute value of the
determinant
tells you how much you scale an area by
well knowing
that both of these statements need to be
true for any matrix
a that has an inverse it gives us a clue
as to at least one way to rule out
matrices that might not have inverses
if i were to tell you that the
determinant of
matrix a is zero will that have an
inverse
well it can't because if this quantity
right over here is zero
or this quantity right over here is zero
that would mean that the absolute value
of the determinant of the inverse of the
matrix needs to be 1 over 0 which is
undefined and so we have an interesting
conclusion here
if the determinant of a matrix is equal
to 0 there is
not going to be an inverse because let's
say that there was
some transformation that determined it
was zero instead of something that's
taking up two-dimensional area to
something else that takes
two-dimensional area
it would transform something that takes
up two-dimensional area to something
that takes no area so maybe a curve like
that
that takes up no area or a line
or a point and if you transform to say a
line
how do you transform back you'd have to
scale up the area infinitely
in order for it to take up some
two-dimensional space so big takeaway
we've just said
if the determinant of a matrix is equal
to zero you're not going to find an
inverse and it actually turns out the
case that
any other matrix you can find an inverse
but i'm not going to prove that just yet
but hopefully you feel good
about this principle right over here